Let's roll back time a little bit.
Let's go back to where we had
$10,000 in our account and
we owed Joe 100 shares of stock.
What can go wrong?
What if, instead of going down,
IBM went up to $150 per share, and
now you want to exit your position?
Well, again, you go to Lisa and
say, hey, Lisa,
do you want to sell me your shares?
She says no.
Well, Nate is still out there,
he's willing to sell.
So again, you buy those shares from
Nate then you return them to Joe.
But this time it costs you $15,000
because the price has gone up.
And remember,
you've got only $10,000 in your account.
So the net result after all this is
said and done is that you're out $5,000.
So if you bet wrong when you short
a stock and the price goes up,
you lose money, and
it can be significant.
So to recap,
we've gone through many of the different
aspects of the mechanics of the market.
We've shown you how hedge
funds exploit the market.
We've shown you different order types.
And we've shown you especially
the details of short selling.
I'll see you at the next lesson.